our first featurelength comedy a number
of eagle-eyed viewers did notice a
certain um quite handsome yet strangely
attired character appear briefly in the
trailer and yes that character was me
this is what I look like in the film
let's put that up just in case you
missed it I'm not even sure how much of
this I'm supposed to say basically it's
a character designed to be the exact
opposite of me in in like every
imaginable respect of course I don't
like making physical contact with people
I don't like when people touch me but in
the movie that the character is is a big
hugger loves to hug so you know it's
basically it's really a character that's
designed just to troll me specifically
and uh and so that's what happens there
as for the rest of the film you know I'm
very confident that it's funny the truth
is I haven't seen it and I've been
asking them to let me see it for weeks
and they insist that we all need to
watch the movie together you can see it
for yourself on uh Friday if you haven't
subscribed yet to Del wire make sure you
subscribe before Friday if you uh
haven't renewed your subscription I
would do all that and make sure you tune
in